i imagine every character is a blank
canvas and what i do is i take my ideas
about the character as informed by the
script and they take their ideas about
the characters informed by the script we
throw them at the canvas and whatever
works for both of us that's what we use
to paint the picture of who that person
is
do actors drive the production of movies
more than people realize
for sure
i think i mean well
in what sense actually that's a better
okay so suppose
once you have a certain name attached
more money will follow there you go that
distribution yeah that's what i thought
you meant
of course yeah that's i mean
a hundred percent 100
um actors you know
an actor being involved in your project
means that like you know a certain
caliber actor means a certain caliber of
budget
you know so certain movies that you want
to be able to do all these crazy things
can only happen if you know a bigger
name gets involved
so um
it's kind of yeah they definitely do
actors
at least at this level you know
what about this myth that actors are
they're at home and they have this pile
of scripts that are just sort of sitting
on their coffee table and they can just
pick which one they want to work on and
it's super easy for them it depends on
the level of actor you know certain
level of actors
yeah they have a ton of offers and they
say no to a bunch of stuff
and the ones that they do say you know
yes to
is you know
far between and it has to hit like a
certain quote and stuff but then you
have like other actors that are actively
campaigning for roles and doing stuff it
depends on the project it depends on if
they connected with the project it
depends on if they want to work with a
certain actor that's already involved
with a project or a certain director
that is already involved with a project
or a producer um you know and it's it's
it's the the business evolves and grows
each
each you know it keeps dying and being
reborn every time something new comes
into it um so
you know
and then you see a lot of actors that
are just going like you know what i want
to make a movie where i'm playing this
role and uh and i'm not getting offered
that so i'm just going to put the whole
production together myself
yeah that's what i was going to ask next
without naming names but i wonder if
there are actors i'm sure there are that
are a victim of their own success and
then people think oh well my little
indie film even though i'm paying them
they'd never say yes to it
yeah probably so then they don't work
because
they're no one's reaching out to them
you know prob maybe maybe but but also i
mean i don't know because right now it's
like you know i've i've had without
naming names i've had tons of actors
where i'm like this person hasn't done a
movie in five years let me see if i can
get them and i get turned down
you know so
so it's maybe they're super picky or
this or that like who knows um you know
i because i for a while i was like let
me hunt down people that have not done
something in a while see if i could get
them and like a lot of the time they're
like nah
okay so so there's a reason then yeah
yeah because i thought like i thought
like you i was like this is yeah if they
haven't done something in a few years
this is the perfect person
but no it's not always it's not always
the case
do you think most actors are waiting by
the phone
or the the tough question because most
people have a phone in their pocket
okay so they're waiting for someone to
email them with a contract or with a
script
i don't know i mean i feel like it's
levels of actors people that are trying
to get their break maybe
um but like i think actors that are
already you know
have blown up and stuff
they're they're more so just they're
already involved with some tv show or
some you know like you have netflix that
has almost every actor or
marvel that has almost every actor doing
something with them now at this point
you know it's a lot of a lot of people
are working right now um it's you know
so it's
it's interesting it's an interesting
time there's a lot of content being made
how much power does an actor have in
getting a film made
i mean it depends on the size of the
actor but like you know
quite a bit i mean you know just to
throw out like a random actor without
like i do not know this person but if
tom cruise said hey i want to make this
movie
that movie is getting made like
you know it's it's if if brad pitt goes
i really like this script this should be
made it's getting made leonardo dicaprio
like there's there's certain you know
and you can't say that about directors
nowadays you know a director might
really love a script the big director
might really love a script that might be
more of a struggle to get made unless
they have one of those actors on board
how do you build trust with a name actor
showing that you care showing that you
care about the
quality of the movie showing that you're
not
going to make them look bad showing that
you have a thought process on why you're
doing things being able to communicate
and fully
realize and and um explain your thought
process
you know
i think that's how
how do you create a safe environment on
set and maybe
you know give because i'm sure there's
people coming up to them while on set
no no no i've never seen that that
usually happens at the very end of the
shoot when the actor's wrapped then
people will be like oh i want to take a
picture with you but everybody in my
experience has been very professional up
until then
okay so you don't need to protect them
in some way no you don't need to be like
oh no no no pictures they're not like
nobody's
you know crew members aren't going like
hey let me take a picture with you like
during the day of filming you know it's
it's when they're wrapped on the whole
movie
you know people will be like hey let's
take pictures well
not so much pictures
i think people probably know that that
there's an etiquette that you don't
cross but i mean like
hey you know what that was great man um
by the way i got this script can i just
um can i just give this to you i don't
think i don't think so yeah i don't i
don't know i don't know if that happens
at all i don't know if that happened
maybe
i've never seen it maybe but i you know
i haven't seen it happen okay all right
so the so pretty much everyone knows
their place and it's there's not a lot
of crossover i think so or i've just
been really lucky you know that too but
i think so
what do you think they want from you
when you're on set with an actor
name talent first timer whatever what do
you think they want from you as a
director i think
most actors that i've dealt with want to
feel like they're not being like hung
out to dry that you're not just like
leaving them in the wind that you have
some type of idea
of storytelling some type of a a clear
idea of what their character arc is and
why they're saying certain things a lot
of the time an actor might want to know
why you feel
their character is saying something in
the script why they're saying these
exact lines what what is the what is the
emotion they're trying to get across and
if you're able to communicate with them
about that and you're talking with them
about that and they understand where the
camera is and what the scene is you know
that that's what they want to know um
you know and just being like you know oh
yeah you're in the scene you're mad like
that's not gonna work you start doing
that then you're gonna start having an
actor that doesn't really
want to
trust in you you have to be able to earn
that trust by having clear communication
of what your vision is for their
character and that vision can change
based upon you know the conversations
you have with them but being able to
have those conversations where you dig
into the character together and you
imagine like i imagine every character
is a blank canvas and what i do is i
take my ideas about the character as
informed by the script and they take
their ideas about the characters
informed by the script we throw them at
the canvas and whatever works for both
of us that's what we use to paint the
picture of who that person is
and so like you know having those
conversations and being able to be like
hey you know remember we talked about in
this situation your character would be
feeling like very reserved because they
don't really like blah blah blah whoever
the whoever the person is or you know
i don't know
or like their mother
you you would have this feeling because
your mother was you know uh this
character reminds you of your mother in
this circumstance or whatever
right um
whatever it is sorry i'm just trying to
come up with some something but uh
being able to call back to those
conversations that you had in the
beginning
is is is i think important
what if it's not working with an actor
how do you how do you gently let them
know
what do you mean not working well what
if
the emotion you want from them is just
not coming out there's a let's say it's
a it's a scene where somebody's begging
someone to to
give them another chance and then
there's just it's just not translated i
like playing to people's strengths
so if somebody you know
if they're not strong in that type of
thing
come up with
a way that your their character would be
reacting that is realistic
to the circumstance
so i play towards somebody's strengths
you don't want to try and you know have
somebody who's not strong at doing a
certain thing do something that they're
not strong at you play towards the
strength that they have
so you adjust the scene in a way that
goes okay well you know maybe this
person's begging for them right but
maybe it's a more
reserved begging that comes in from you
know that bubbles up from inside and
they're welling back tears and they're
trying to beg but they don't know how
right
maybe they're not able to keep eye
contact they're breaking eye contact
they can't look at the person because of
how ashamed they are inside of himself
right you change the whole scene
right to fit what the person can do
and it still keeps the emotion of the
moment but maybe just shifts the meaning
of the moment right but it still maybe
fits the character's arc that you're
creating so you find while working with
somebody what their strengths are and
then you play towards their strengths
you don't want to hang them out to dry
and have them do something that they're
not strong at
that's excellent so you're not making an
introverted character who's more
internal um become this like
lioness and start roaring if that's not
their style anyway right exactly
exactly unless it's something that
really needs to push for that moment and
they've been playing introverted from
the beginning
because that's what you had talked about
but they knew they were going to ramp up
to this right but like you know
ultimately like you know
people show you and tell you who they
are and what they play towards like you
listen to them you have to listen to
what somebody's good at like you know
when you're when you're looking at it
like a football game like if you're
there and somebody's you're running back
and you hand them the football and they
run the ball over and over again you
know uh you're not gonna go hey listen
you're really good at running the ball
let's have you be the quarterback now
right
like you're gonna be like okay like you
know play towards somebody's strong suit
like
so you would just you adjust things and
maybe they can throw the ball and maybe
find out they can throw the ball so you
let them throw the ball one time and
that's good but you you you got to play
towards what somebody's good at